[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis 2018 le pea paris-saclay
expérimente une solution de
stationnement intelligent en étroite
coopération avec les collectivités
locales parking c'est clair c'est en
fait une application mobile qui
permettent de rendre visibles en temps
réel l'ensemble des places de
stationnement qui sont disponibles sur
le territoire que ce soit des places
publiques ou privées dans des parkings
en ouvrage en souterrain ou en voirie le
pea paris saclay a sélectionné le
groupement mobility bike aulas qui s'est
chargé de concevoir une plateforme de
services de stationnement et de mobilité
en co-traitance avec deux start-up zen
clark qui est chargé de mutualiser de
rendre accessibles les parkings privés
et parkings map qui a développé un
observatoire du stationnement à l'aide
de capteurs magnétiques et optiques qui
ont été agencées sur les espaces publics
toutes ces données sont agrégées ainsi
que celle de disponibilité des parkings
privés et remonte dans l'application
mobile qui est accessible aux usagers
ainsi que sur les panneaux dynamiques
qui ont été installés en entrée de
quartier des ags de moulon et de
polytechnique aujourd'hui parking saclay
c'est plus de 1000 places superviser
dont 500 mutualisés
alors king saclay encourage le report
des véhicules en voirie vers les poches
de stationnement en ouvrage ainsi
mettant à profit ces espaces pour les
modes actifs et des quartiers plus
apaisé après trois années de recherche
et développement parking saclay a
démontré que de façon à gilles
permettait de répondre à la demande
croissante et évolutive en stationnement
qui est induite par la livraison des
nouvelles opérations immobilières c'est
pour cette raison que les acteurs
institutionnels compétent en matière de
mobilité telles que l'agglomération
paris saclay et en stationnement pour
les villes de gif sur yvette et de
palaiseau ont convenu de signer une
convention de coopération publique
public avec le pea paris saclay pour
pérenniser le service jusqu'en 2024
le territoire dispose aujourd'hui d'un
véritable observatoire du stationnement
qui lui permet de mieux appréhender la
place d'une véhicule en coeur des
quartiers sur le campus paris saclay en
attendant la mise en service de la ligne
18 du métro automatique